if you can expose someone to a stimuli
and get a consistent outcome
a lot of marketers and sales people like
to talk about the internal thoughts that
someone's had like first they need
awareness and then they need blah blah
and then so they're basically just make
up they reverse engineer fictitious
steps of someone's mental thought
process when they have no evidence to
support what someone's thinking at all
and so i don't find it useful because
it's not useful like what are the things
that are useful these are the things
that are observable that we can drive
action towards that that we create an
outcome and then we have a feedback loop
and so if we have those things
then we can move the variables and get
closer to where we're trying to go and
the feelings although i recognize that
they exist they're not helpful in trying
to edit
what our activities are
i would say there are days that i feel
like less energized or things like that
for sure not about like the big picture
of like i don't believe that this cause
is not worthy but i do think a lot of
people have that too where they're like
what i'm doing is meaningless right and
then i get into i think everything's
meaningless and then we can just create
whatever meaning you know we choose to
because if we don't believe in a capital
m meaning which a lot of people disagree
with that's fine but if you don't
believe in a capital end meaning i think
that's very freeing because then you can
create little meaning for whatever you
want and so if you believe you can then
choose to architect your own life in
whatever ways that you deem meaningful
and make the activities you do aligned
with that meaning the difference between
capital m meaning and little meaning and
this is kind of like the basis of
nihilism which people have like a very
negative viewpoint around which i'm not
entirely sure about why but like
capitalism meaning means that like this
is the meaning of life period
like for everyone this is the meaning of
life whereas if we say that there is no
single agreed upon meaning of life and
then people say well then that is your
big meaning of life and i'm like yes
you're right i believe that there is no
meaning that is the thing that i that i
believe and they're like well then that
is the capital then sure that's my
capital meaning is that there is no
meaning
what's the implication of that it means
now that we
have meaning making machines in our
brain and so we get to create and
destroy meaning as we see fit and so if
we choose an activity and we deem that
goal meaningful because we think it's
more interesting or it energizes us then
we can ascribe meaning to that and do
more of it and what's nice about not
having capital m meaning is that that
can shift right that might be good for a
season and then it can shift i will say
that the downside of not having capital
meaning which i consider to be religion
off the shelf is that it's more
difficult because you have no one who's
saying here's the big box of rules you
can read it and then that way you don't
have to make the decisions about it but
i think it's more difficult but
ultimately more rewarding if you have
reasoning behind why you believe what
you believe because then you have to
independently come up with your own
conclusions about those things it also
makes it malleable so that if you get
new data or new evidence then you can
change your mind which a lot of people
again have difficulty with but like if
you change the information
then it would make sense that if it
materially changes the outcome that you
the way that you believe about something
should change and i think a lot of
people identify with their beliefs
as a part of themselves rather than as
what i prefer to call them which is
assumptions because they work the same
way what's the difference in belief and
assumption not a lot right the only
difference is just what we call the word
and so assumptions are based on
things that we've observed and then we
assume something as a result and so i
would say that beliefs are just
assumptions and but when you call them
that they become less tied to your
identity if you have an assumption you
don't say
you challenged my assumption it's like
well hey challenge my assumption oh
that's great i i was assuming this it
must be this and then they become much
more flexible and then we don't tie our
egos into them and i think ultimately it
serves more people better in the long
run
i feel passionately about my viewpoint
of the world mostly because i struggled
and i was in so much pain for such a
long period of time i'm only sharing
this despite the fact that i get
attacked for sharing this
because there are people who this does
resonate with but when there is no
required meaning then a lot of language
changes which is should must need have
to
like all of these things no longer exist
because there is no capital m meaning so
i don't should have to must need to
anything and so a lot of the
expectations that we bury ourselves into
that weigh us down are just implied
shoulds have to's musts and so if all of
those disappeared then in a lot of ways
it's very liberating and so for me in
business
it allows me to take actions even though
i know that i shouldn't or must not or
other people would judge me for not
doing it the way that they thought i
should do it because there are no rules
which is why that was the preference to
the book it's like there are no rules we
can live our life whatever way we want
to live it
and that's okay
i read a youtube comment the other day
it's like hey you know you talk a lot
about being sad and like how have you
been able to x y and z and i don't
identify with being a sad person i think
i
i have been sad in the past but i also
don't think that there's a problem with
being sad
and so
i think that there's just so much power
in acceptance it's like so many people
make themselves miserable because they
think that they shouldn't be who they
are and they shouldn't feel how they
feel and so much of the medication that
gets prescribed right now is because
someone's like oh i'm anxious and why do
we feel like someone shouldn't be
anxious they are human why do we feel
like we shouldn't feel sad we are human
why do we feel like we shouldn't feel
frustrated or angry we are human and so
i think it's one of the most like
interesting things or phenomena where if
you have a line which is the normal
human existence and you have points
above the line and points below the line
you have the median right or the the
middle point and people want to not feel
the things below the line and then we
ascribe or label the things below the
line as bad and things above the line is
good when
all of it is and so i think that if we
just accept that and accept ourselves
and accept the feelings that we
experience as things that we experience
like rain and weather and sunshine it's
not like rain is bad not like sunshine's
good it just is not like happiness is
good or happiness is bad or sadness is
bad or sadness is good we just label it
that way and i think the labels create
more suffering than anything that we
ever actually experience so when you're
sad do you try to
not be sad no i actually don't think
about it much i think a lot of people
spend a lot of time and effort trying to
figure out how they feel because they
want to then judge or label themselves
as i'm doing well or not well like a lot
of effort goes into showing like how do
i feel about this i mean my follow-up
question be like why do you care why
does it matter and that's why when you
asked way long ago about like how much
do you think feelings matter i don't
think they matter at all
like what would the case for feelings
mattering be
then why do you believe they exist it's
a good question and it gets really
interesting because it's like how i
experience a feeling that i label in my
head is sadness is it the same way you
experience the thing that you like it's
like seeing green and i see green and
you see green what if all of our greens
are different right i mean it's it gets
very interesting like that but i think
that i experienced something and if we
were to just measure it based on like
brain activity and like heart rate i
would say that i become aroused in the
literal sense uh from experiencing what
i would deem as emotions and so if we
were to describe it or define the term
in that way i think i experience
emotions and so i mean i'm fairly
confident i experience emotions if we
were to try and measure it that way then
that's how i would say yes i do
experience them but the question is just
like how important are they and then it
would be like for what if it's for
accomplishment not very important for
fitness not very important you know if
if we're saying how important is emotion
for
love which is another emotion right it
becomes like amorphous trying to go to
amorphous but then you say okay well for
defining love by what i'm willing to
endure to continue to keep something
then how important is it well it depends
on how much i've conditioned myself to
accept this thing so like if i want to
stay married it's probably far more
effective to condition someone to stay
married because that is the
external consequence of a good marriage
as you stay together right i'm just
saying like we're just purely measuring
from out from external circumstances and
so i think trying to measure and define
things is what i actually geek out on
and i really enjoy i think most people
get bored of tears when i talk about
this stuff so i don't talk about it much
but that's the stuff that like um when
when we keep peeling back layers of like
why do you think you're able to get out
of you know a difficult place in your
life or why do you think you're able to
go through these things
a lot of it is because
i believe that i will redefine terms and
so
we'll have some instance or something
that i should do and i will redefine it
or i'll say i i don't should i can just
accept it and that's why the biggest
refrain that i have in my head for like
my own mental illness is just like and
that's okay period
like i don't wanna go to that thing
that's okay